let's do some bonding in bridesmaids
Anju we do well we we we did a little
bit of rehearsal like that and a lot of
the film was improvised so we were kind
of I was prepared for that a little bit
well we kind of just played a lot of
games like there's a scene where we're
kind of sitting on a cop car and I play
a cop in the phone right and we would
just play would you rather a lot you
know that game would you rather it's a
pub game yeah yeah like would you rather
have a nipple on the end of your nose
or a tooth growing out of your cheek
would you rather have to ease a bath
full of poo or have a small bird poo in
your mouth every morning for the rest
area would you go for you get the bird
no no if you have to do it every day for
the rest of your life did you get used
to it proposed will become your friends
birds
I suppose a paper is only quite wait
look go for a very small bird birds oh
you don't get to choose
ask you what cuz I don't think one yeah
when you or so when you're a Glastonbury
right and you're backstage and there's
Beyonce who's waiting for you by Fred
yeah so would you rather when you go up
to her in this Peter would you rather
sneeze and have both barrels blow snot
all down your face Oh coughing [__]
yourself
[Laughter]
[Applause]
both of them are night now yet again I'm
going to have to go with [__] [__]
no she wouldn't know see you bye it's a
weird example because Beyonce and I are
so close no it's just you know we hang
out a lot just like to dance together
more than cook I love to cook really
really close
[Music]
you